Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge mit mir, Stefan Hiese, Und die... Das Podcast UFO. Völlig richtig. Wir kommen ja immer jetzt immer samstags raus, das heißt Podcast-Ufer heißt für viele Leute Wochenende, hoch den Podcast-Catcher, Wochenende steht vor der Tür, wird in ganz Deutschland, in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, Bundestag, Reichstag, verschiedene Organe, die sich unterstützen, Podcast-Tag, Samstag, Samstag, alle Freunde. Ein grosses Kompliment von der ganzen Redaktion und mir übrigens dafür, dass du das hingekriegt hast, dass wir so ein regelmäßiges Datum haben, wo wir erscheinen. Das ist man von uns anders gewohnt. Mittlerweile schleicht sich da fast sowas wie Professionalität ein. Nein, ach hör auf jetzt, ich werde ganz rot. Ich habe seit einer Woche nicht geschlafen, weil direkt nach der letzten Folge, wo wir gesagt haben, schickt Stefan Songs, damit
er euch von Orwimmer befreien kann, weil er dann euch sagt, wie der Song heißt, weil ich ja letzte Woche noch großsprünglich behauptet habe, ja klar, kenne ich alle Songs. Eine Woche habe ich einen Orwimmer von einem Dreckssong, den mir ein Zuschauer eingeschickt hat, den ich nicht erahnen kann.
Das ist
Venga Boys. eingeschickt hat, den ich nicht erraten kann.
Das ist Wenger Boys.
Ja, okay.
Das ist
das habe ich mir auch schon gedacht.
Das ist der Wenger Bass.
Wie heißt der Party Bus?
Diese Dreck-Songs, die kenne ich aber alle nicht.
Wenger
San Francisco
Disco Ja, einfach mal Wenger-Bass, Venga-Boys-Bass. Okay, welches der Song dann geflogen ist? Aber ich finde es gut, dass du deinen Meister gefunden hast bei den Venga-Boys, einfach so. Sämtliche Wagner-Overtüren, alles kein Problem, aber Venga-Boys, da ist einfach der Stefan Titel. Nee, kein Problem, Wenger Boys, keine Ahnung, was ist Wenger Boys? Ein bisschen stolz darauf, dass ich es nicht weiss. Boom, boom, boom? Nein. Nee, Bass, nee, Partyboss. Nee, nee, nee. Projekte Party, Wengerbus? Ja, genau. So, oder? Ja, geiler Anfang auch. Mit der Hupe, genial. Man stellt sich vor wie so ein Bus, so ein Comicartiger Bus, so auf und ab, der nicht ganz runde Reifen hat, so auf und ab fährt. Ja, es gibt ja manchmal so Partybusse, so von so Omnibusveranstaltern, wo man dann manchmal teilweise eine Busreise bucht irgendwie und dann plötzlich irgendwie im Sambabus ist und sich denkt so, was ist denn eigentlich hier los? Noch schlimmer im Comedy-Bus. Der fährt nämlich manchmal durch Köln.
Wobei, das war auch mal, als wir in New York waren und ich glaube am ersten Tag angekommen waren, noch so ein bisschen jetlagged am Times Square rumstanden, mit müden, aber grossen Augen standen wir da rum und plötzlich war hinter uns aus dem Nichts so ein Bus, wo einfach eine große, die Seite war einfach eine grosse Glasfront und die Leute sassen seitlich, wie so eine Art Tribüne, auf uns gerichtet und davor stand so ein Comedian, der irgendwelche Gags gemacht hat, war aber so ein Comedy-Bus, eine fahrende Tribüne, die gemeint hat, vor uns anhalten zu müssen. Zwei dusseligen Deutschen, die einfach plötzlich auf einer Bühne standen, ohne es zu wissen. Und dann einfach, look the und alle lachen uns aus. Und wir versuchen wegzulaufen, der Bus fährt immer neben uns her die ganze Zeit. Sie lachen uns die ganze Zeit aus. Dieses Sitcon-Publikum lacht uns die ganze Zeit aus. Wir verstehen sie auch nicht, weil eine Glasscheibe dazwischen ist, ist alles sehr dumpf. Wir sehen nur ihre Fratzen, wir sehen nur ihre verzerrten Fratzen und ihre scharfen Zeigefinger. Was war das? Ich glaube, das war irgendeine Showtour oder so was, wo dann irgendwie was passiert irgendwo. Aber eigentlich eine coole Idee, alle im Bus nach links schauen zu lassen, alle zur Seite raus und dann eine Fassade ganz glasig zu machen und die andere dann zu. Aber sehr gefährlich, wenn man von einem Auto mal reinfährt. Aber ich meine, du hast ja eine gewisse Fläche Fenster pro Bus, die du verwenden kannst.
Also warum nicht alle ein großes Fenster machen, anstatt diese ganzen kleinen Minifenster, wo eh keiner durchgucken kann, weil die zu klein sind, sondern einfach ein riesiges Fenster macht. Ja genau, wie es ja die Glass Bottom Boats gibt und wo der ganze Bodenglas ist, wo man runtergucken kann. Wie verwirrend ist das für Fische eigentlich? Weil die gucken nach oben und sehen fliegende Menschen und denken sich, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich los? Aber die haben sich seit mehreren Jahren schon aufgehört, Fragen zu stellen. Die ganze Zeit passiert so viel Crab da unten, im Basen des Wortes. Aber ich glaube, das ist nicht gut. Weisst du, da kommt dann so ein alter Furby vorbeigeschwommen und der denkt einfach nur, was ist das jetzt so für ein Scheiß, was ist das jetzt? Und der eine fische nur noch so routiniert, steigt dann so auf dieses Batteriefach, damit Batterien rausfallen. Wir sind hier drin geblieben, ja, Eduard und Karl sind an Land gegangen und wollten sich den Scheiß geben, wir sind extra im Wasser geblieben, um so einen Crap nicht mitzumachen und Und jetzt kommt hier fucking Furby und Polly Pocket kommt hier runter. Polly Pocket. Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf. Ich bin extra hier drin geblieben. Furby, ja genau. Es gibt Glass Bottom Boats, wo du dann den Boden langkommen kannst. Warum ist das im Flugzeug nicht, habe ich mich gefragt. Das wäre doch fantastisch. Weil die Leute wahrscheinlich viereinhalb Stunden schreien würden. Und denken, ich sterbe, ich falle, ich sterbe, ich falle. Und dann prepare your landing. Okay. Und dann schneiden sie sich an, ich sterbe, ich falle, ich sterbe, ich falle und dann prepare your landing und dann schreien sie sich an, ich sterbe, ich falle, ich sterbe, ich falle und dann geht es Essen kurz, dann still, dann ist so eine halbe Stunde so still und dann ist der Erste fertig, dann beginnt der Erste zu schreien, ich sterbe, ich sterbe, ich falle, ich sterbe und dann geht es irgendwann wieder los, aber eigentlich doch geil, weil, also ich finde diese Fenster weird, erstmal hat mir irgendein Inieur gesagt, ja, diese Fenster, die am Rand drin sind, diese Bullaugen, machen das extrem gefährlich. Ja. Und da dachte ich mir, ja gut, also auch nicht so gefährlich, also wahrscheinlich, weil es ja... Du liebst es einfach, Aussagen von Experten zu relativieren einfach. Ja, so gefährlich ist das ja. So gefährlich kann es ja nicht sein. Es sterben mir nicht jährlich sehr viele Menschen, also es ist ja prozentual immer noch sicherer als die andere Formen der Vorbewegung. Aber hatten die ersten Flugzeuge dann keine Fenster, wo dann alle einfach wie in so einer großen Zahnpastatube gefangen waren? Richtig, auch alle geschrieben, ich sterbe, ich sterbe, ich sterbe. Das Röhrenprinzip ist glaube ich besser, wenn es aufbricht mit so Bullaugen ist es glaube ich nicht so toll. Aber der Mensch will ja gucken, wo er hinfliegt, was passiert, aber nicht so geil, weil du guckst halt immer, meiste Zeit, auf weiße Wolken. Oder auf Tragflächen. Oder auf Tragflächen. Wo man nicht mal sagt, mach da doch ein LED drauf, LED-Screen und lass da irgendwie Scrubs oder so laufen oder findet Nemo, damit man was verschauen hat. Aber ich glaube, das Problem war, dass als Flugzeuge erst entwickelt wurden, waren die Menschen skeptisch und dachten, das kann nicht sein, ein riesiger Stahlwurm kann sich nicht emporschwingen. Ich glaube, aber die ersten wurden gefakt. Genau, und deswegen haben die die alle in den Bus gesetzt, komplett lichtig zugemacht und dann gesagt, so jetzt fliegen wir mal hin und dann fahren die um die Ecke. Da draußen waren so Männer, die daran gewackelt haben. Genau. Und dann fahren die irgendwie einmal um die Ecke.
Und dann fahren die um die Ecke. Draußen waren so Männer, die daran gewackelt haben. Und dann fahren die irgendwie einmal um die Ecke. Und dann steigen die alle aus und alle wow. Und irgendwann kam da mal jemand drauf, irgendein Journalist, irgendein Investigativjournalist. Wir hätten gerne Fenster. Ja, so ein MTV-Journalist. Hat da mal recherchiert und hat gesagt, fliegen wir wirklich? Oder ist das nur ein Bus? Und dann, was? Über. Stell These, sind wir nicht nur ein Bus, in dem gewackelt wird. Und dann hat dieser MTV-Journalist so lange gearbeitet und so lange Musikclips veröffentlicht, bis die Fluggesellschaften tatsächlich gezwungen waren, Fenster einzubauen. Also das ist tatsächlich wahr. So wurden die Fenster eingebaut, damit die Leute sagen können, genau andersrum war es bei Frank Elstner. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das sagen darf. Ich muss recherchieren, vielleicht muss ich es rausschneiden. Weil Frank Elstner hat mal eine Sendung im Flugzeug gemacht, eine Fernsehsendung im Flugzeug und dachte, okay, alle sitzen im Flugzeug und wir fliegen irgendwo hin und es ist halt eine Fernsehsendung aus dem Flugzeug. Mega geil. Und die haben tatsächlich dann irgendwie Kameras und Licht und alles im Flugzeug eingebaut und hatten dann eine komplette Sendung im Flugzeug. Starten irgendwo, fliegen und landen. Das Problem war, die Zuschauer haben schlicht nicht geglaubt, dass das Flugzeug wirklich fliegt. Aber es ist geflogen. Aber die Zuschauer haben gesagt, nee, das steht doch irgendwo rum.
Die Leute haben es halt einfach nicht geglaubt. Und deswegen hat Frank Elzer dieses Konzept beerdigt, obwohl er sich größte Mühe gegeben hat, dass dieses Flugzeug da irgendwie tatsächlich fliegt und eingebaut und Kameras und alles. Aber die Zuschauer haben einfach gesagt, nee, es fliegt doch nicht. Doch! Nee, das steht doch einfach rum. Doch, es fliegt! Wir wollen es erst so machen, wie ihr es sagt. Aber da haben wir uns richtig viel Mühe und dann hat Karl auch noch ein Flugzeug. Was haben wir jetzt, können wir fliegen? Wir haben extra eine Lizenz geholt, dass man da aufstehen darf während dem Flug und dass Kameraleute da sitzen dürfen und jetzt... Nee,, das steht rum. Das steht rum. Nein! Guck doch! Komm doch, komm mit! Bei der nächsten Sendung kommst du mit! Wie geil! Ein Format, was zu vortrittlich ist, dass Leute glauben, dass es wirklich ist. Aber das ist einfach so... War gestern aber schon vor seiner Zeit. Ja, absolut. Aber auch ein dusseliges Prinzip. Es ist halt ein bisschen... Aber es ist ein cooles Gimmick einfach so. Du kannst halt einfach eine coole Sendung machen. Also an sich ist es halt irgendwie so ein, ich weiß nicht, was das für eine Sendung war, Quiz-Sendung oder so. Von Hamburg nach Bremen oder sowas. Und dann steigen die da aus, haben eine Sendung gemacht und dann gucken sie alle um, ah ja, fuck, jetzt sind wir in Bremen. Ich weiß es auch nicht. Und dann sind alle wieder zurückfahren, Auto oder was. Vielleicht ist es so eine Art Quiz-Flugzeug oder so oder dann irgendwie, deswegen Quiztaxi auch die Leute, der steht doch, das sind Monitore, nein, wir fahren durch Hamburg, der steht doch nur in der Garage. Ja, weil es denke ich mir bei jeder Form von, auch bei Quiztaxi und sowas, die sind doch gecastet, das kommt ja immer, das ist doch Fake alles erstmal, Menschen glauben viele Sachen nicht mehr. Das stimmt, das stimmt, das ist besonders lustig. Also bestimmt ist vieles gefakt im Fernsehen, aber gerade wenn man an der Fernsehsendung selber mitmacht und dann die Kommentare liest bei irgendeiner Aktion oder sowas und dann einfach sieht, das ist doch gefakt und man weiss halt, das ist einfach nicht gefakt. Aber ja, schwer zu sein. Die haben die Alpakas doch nicht wirklich angemalt. Die würden doch von der Herde verstoßen werden. Das ist doch alles gefakt. Stimmt, nein, haben haben nie Alpakas angemalt. Wir hätten nie das Leben von zwei Alpakas in den Abgrund gestürzt für den miesen Gag. Wir haben doch vorher recherchiert, dass man das nicht mehr andab. Klar! Wir sind doch Journalisten. Wir sind doch Journalisten, wir arbeiten doch mit den ganzen Suchtools. Ja, wir haben doch so, welcher Feiertag ist heute? Tag der Leberwurst ist so heute. Können wir doch einen coolen Beitrag darüber machen. Über grob gegen fein. Fein gegen grob. Zwei unterschiedliche. Geil, sehr gut, danke. Schau hier auf. Das kann man doch total viel machen. Tag der Mohnblume, Mohnkuchen, Mohnblumen, Blumenladen, Schnecke. Ja. So, perfekt. Ehrlich gesagt, ich finde es mega. Flugzeug einfach unten, alle Fenster, die man hat, nach unten und dann kann man nach unten gucken. Ich finde das ganz toll. Ich glaube, es würde mindestens einen Nervenzusammenbruch pro Flug geben. Vor allem weiss man im Vorhinein, was man da dabei ist. Die geistig Schwachen sollen halt nicht damit fliegen. Und die schauen nach oben. Du musst ja nicht das Glasbaut im Flugzeug buchen für deine Reise nach Malle. Aber ist unter den Passagieren nicht dann irgendwie der Motor oder das Gepäck oder so? Also die sehen dann nur das Gepäck die ganze Zeit. Du musst einfach das Gepäck sehen. Und so ein Hund, der mit so einem jämmerlichen Blick hochkommt. Und ein Pferd. Pferde können mitfliegen, ja. Und Kerosin, so einen großen Kerosin-Tank. Genau wie so ein Swimmingpool, das immer so hin und her schwappt die ganze Zeit.
Also ich fände es fast noch geiler, du machst es mir echt schmackhaft, diesen armen Hund zu sehen, der sagt, ich bin in einem Käfig, in einem Raum, der abgeschlossen ist, ich bin in zwei Gefängnissen.
Also ich bin, selbst wenn ich hier rauskäme, bin ich immer noch eingesperrt.
Und selbst wenn ich da rauskomme, bin ich tot. Selbst wenn ich da rauskomme, bin ich immer noch tausend Kilometer in der Luft. Der andere Hund, der sagt, wir fliegen nicht. Wir fliegen nicht. Aber es wackelt doch. Ja, da rüttelt jemand eine. Und das Pferd so, oh Gott, die Diskussion wieder. Und Frau Gelzner so, diese Diskussion wieder. Ach ja, Flugzeuge, oder? Toll. Frau Gelzner ist ja im Prinzip, jetzt weiß ich nicht, wie sie diesen Gag beenden soll, kein Glass-Bottom-Flugzeug, sondern ein Glass-Front-Guy. Ja, ja, finde ich gut. Warum hat man sich auf Glasaugen geeinigt? Anstatt Fleece oder Seide oder was? Marmor. Marmor ist auch eine gute Idee. Und Luxusliner einfach so Marmor. Wir haben Fenster aus Marmor. Sind Augen ganz rund? Nein, die sind nicht komplett rund. Nein, die sind schon eher ovalig. Wird es dann jetzt gern? Du meinst das menschliche Auge? Genau. Das ist eine Kugel. Eine perfekte Kugel. Aber auch tatsächlich hat mir auch jemand geschrieben, weil ich mal gesagt habe, meine Augen fühlen sich mal zu gross an. Ja, stimmt. Und da hat auch jemand geschrieben, hey du, wenn sich deine Augen zu gross anfühlen, kann es ein Anzeichen für eine schwere Schilddrüsenkrankheit sein und tödlich.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen so fast noch schlimmer als Nettdoktor. zu gross anfühlen, kann es ein Anzeichen für eine schwere Schilddrüsenkrankheit sein und tödlich.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen so,
fast noch schlimmer als Net-Doktor sind,
wenn du einen Podcast machst,
wird regelmäßig, also eigentlich in jeder Folge auch ungefragt,
das war jetzt zumindest nur... Absolut ungefragt.
Nee, das stimmt nicht. Du hast gefragt,
falls sie denkt, was mit mir falsch ist und so. Okay.
Du hast schon wirklich einfach den Devil
gepokt. Ich habe ihn beschworen, ja. Und auch irgendwie, es gibt ja diesen Running Gag, dass sich meine Stimme verändert hat, auch da. Logopäden haben sich gemeldet und gesagt so, ja, kann irgendwie sein, Entzündung oder sowas. Es gibt nicht sowas wie einen zweiten Stimmbruch. Und dann der schönste Satz war, ich werde mir das jetzt noch ein paar Folgen lang anhören. Da dachte ich mir, yes, ein neuerörer, der zugewonnen, die Logopäden, die alle sagen, es war diese Logopädenvereinigung, alle gebannt den Podcast-Ufo hören, einfach nur um zu hören, als Fallstudie, ob sich meine Stimme verändert hat oder nicht. Aber wie gut, du musst nichts an deinem Leben verändern und Leute beobachten dich gesundheitlich. Das will man doch eigentlich. Eigentlich grossartig. Keine Einschränkung, aber Leute, ich gucke mir das noch ein paar Folgen an.
Wie gut ist das? Ich beobachte das, weil ich dachte, ich habe mich wirklich in guten Händen gefühlt.
Und stell dir mal vor, wenn wir in die Geschichte eingehen, als der Podcast, der irgendwann so einen ganz schweren
Verlauf einer Krankheit einfach fantastisch dokumentiert. Das stimmt. Und dann so ab welcher Folge hätte man anfangen können?
Und dann ist das so ein Lehrbeispiel in Büchern. Genau. Wir haben alle weggesehen.
Wir haben alle weggesäht. Niemand hat hingehört, wie Florentin langsam zerfällt. Ja, und wäre geil, wenn so Logopäden jetzt einfach anfangen, diesen Podcast aus medizinischen Gründen zu hören die ganze Zeit. Es gibt ja auch bei YouTube-Kanälen ab und zu, dass Leute schreiben so, hey, du hast da einen Leberfleck auf der Stirn, der wird immer grösser und dann tatsächlich konnte man dadurch irgendwas Schlimmes abwenden. Ja, nur ein Edding. Ich habe Spding. Ich habe Spaghetti gegessen. Spaghetti-Boron. Aber auch wenn die mich immer so wütend wegskippen, weil die bei mir nichts erkennen. Der nuschelt nur ein bisschen. Wütend weg, immer 15 Sekunden vor, bis du widersprichst. Ja, und danach. Wo dann auch so aus den Transkripten immer so gestrichen ist, so mit so einem dicken Edding-Strich. Wo ist der Kranke-Dum? Ja, egal, komm, weiter, weiter, weiter, weiter. Wo Bottom Boat. Ich sag's auch gern. Ich sag gern Glass Bottom Boat.om-Boat-Production. The website for names. Ach so, jetzt verstehe ich meine eigene Idee erst. Geil, gute Idee. So sind wir. Du sagst irgendwas Geniales und ich sage dir, warum das gerade Geniale. Apropos genial, wir haben noch gar nicht gesagt, von wem das Intro war, Julian. Das erwähne ich. Vielen Dank an Julian, fantastisch. Kontrapunktisch gearbeitet, wirklich hier, da war, da die Gliessando, Perpeto Continuo, voll die Coda auch fantastisch eingelocht. Alles war dabei. Also wirklich, alles war drin. Grossartig. Mittlerweile melden sich auch immer mehr Leute, die sagen, ich habe mich bewusst dagegen entschieden, ein Intro einzuschicken. Und das finde ich toll. Dankeschön. Euch muss es auch geben, ihr seid die stillen Helden dieses Podcast-Projekts, die sagen, ich schicke heute kein Intro ein. Das ist völlig korrekt. Das finde ich auf jeden Fall eine gute Idee. Vielleicht auch mal, machen wir noch mal eine Folge mit Musik mit, wo einfach so konstant so Musik drunter ist, eigentlich so rauschen. Ich freue mich schon wieder sehr auf die Live-Shows, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Ja? Ja, ich freue mich da sehr drauf. Like said, die kleinen Snacks. Ja, also ich war jetzt zum ersten Mal wieder bei einer Stand-up-Show.
Da habe ich mir angeschaut, hat auch gut funktioniert, alles. Hazel Brugger hat nämlich eine Show gespielt. Das war fantastisch, an einem richtig cool am Rhein direkt, das war eine richtig coole Location. Nur leider konnte ich mir die Show nicht angucken, weil genau in meiner Blickrichtung zwei grosse Scheinwerfer hinter ihr standen, die genau auf mich gezeigt haben. Das war die unangenehmste anderthalb Stunden meines Lebens, weil ich konnte einfach nicht auf die Bühne gucken. Ich konnte nicht, ich musste immer zum Dom gucken. Der war nämlich, den konnte man sehen, weil da war der Rhein, da war der Dom, ob ich den Dom anguckt und in Thessburg hat geredet. Es war wie so ein Podcast hören am Rheinstrand so ein bisschen. Und man kann sich nicht bewegen. Grauenhaft, es war grauenhaft. Ich konnte nicht hingucken, ich bin sofort erblindet. Wow, aber waren das wirklich so Spotlights einfach so direkt auf dich? Ja, so Spotlights auf mich. Aber ich meine, jeder Mensch, der so Bühnen vorbereitet oder auch so Akustik macht, weiß, ja, es gibt halt ein paar Plätze, die kriegen nichts mit. Auch so Akustik, wenn du so die Wellen ausrechnest und so, ja, der eine kriegt halt, da cancelt sich genau alles aus, der hört nichts, gar nichts. Aber ja, es muss halt ein paar Leute geben. Es werden ein paar Leute während der Show geopfert. Ja, du machst einfach ein paar Opfer. Im Gesamterlebnis geopfert. Und manche Leute sitzen auch drin und wissen, ja, ich bin das Opfer gerade. Aber mal bin ich nicht, mal bin ich es. Jetzt war ich gestern auch schon das Opfer. Bin doof gelaufen. Ich sitze neben einem Kühlschrank, der halt die ganze Zeit vibriert und dröhnt. Das ist tatsächlich einer meiner Lieblingsmomente, weil es gibt ja so Kühlschränke, die nicht ständig arbeiten, so Teilzeitkühlschränke. Wirst du mich verarschen eigentlich? Wieso manövierst du dich da gerade so rum? Du bist aber erst noch am besten, wie Kühlschränke funktionieren. Ja, natürlich. Ich wollte es dir ja erklären als Laie, als Kühlleihe, als warmer Junge, der einfach nicht weiss, wie die kühle Welt funktioniert. Dann lasse ich mich mal vom Kühl-Experten ... Cool King, I'm the Cool King. Es gibt immer mehr Leute, die mich Cool King nennen, einfach weil ich mich so gut mit Kühlung auskenne.
Ich glaube, du willst eher, dass Leute nicht Cool King nennen.
Nö, das stimmt nicht. Es gibt tatsächlich Leute, die sagen, hey, Cool King, und dann sage ich, dann habe ich so einen coolen Groß, brr, brr, so. Okay, den Anorak an, gut. Und manche arbeiten durchgehend und manche machen auch so, dann machen sie Feierabend und dann hören sie auf.
Und dann gibt es manchmal den Moment, wo so ein Raum, so ein gewisses Grundrauschen im Raum ist. Und dann hört der Kühlschrank auf und dann wird es ganz leiser. Ganz leise, ja. Und das ist so ein, wow, so eine, Achtung, eine laute Stille. Eine uhrenbetäubende Stille. Eine Stille, die wirklich einen schockiert, auffällt. Ich finde fast, das ist total interessant, im Schnitt sind wir gerade auch schon wieder für die Serie. Und das Spannende ist, dass wenn man wirklich unangenehm Stille erzählen will, eigentlich ist das nie Stille. Im Idealfall ist es dann der Nurton vom Set, den man mal aufnimmt, wenn niemand spricht, weil da immer so ein Grundrauschen ist oder Autobahn oder wie das Kühlschrank oder so oder halt das Klicken einer Uhr zum Beispiel. Es fühlt sich viel stiller an, wenn man Geräusche hat. Stille ist egal, das hast du ja selten auch. Ich finde das so spannend, weil ich komme ja aus Carmen, direkt an den zwei Autobahnen, an der A1 und der A2, und ich habe mein Leben lang immer dieses Grauschen der Autobahn. Oh ja. Die ganze Zeit. Das heißt, erst mal als du dann irgendwie im Flugzeug warst, hast du absolute Stille, ja auch da nicht, erst als du weggezogen bist, hast du absolute Stille erlebt. Genau, hier absolut stille in Köln. Und da ist es, was ist das, ist irgendwas kaputt. Ja. Das ist ja wie bei The Office UK, wo es auch eine Szene gibt, wo Tim sein Mikrofon ausmacht. Also The Office ist ja so eine Mockumentary, als werden die in der Dokumentation gefilmt. Und dann macht er sein Mikrofon aus und dann ist es wirklich eine Zeit lang absolut still. Dann gibt es einfach keine Tonspur, also absolute Stille, gar nichts, wo die Macher auch meinten, ja einige Leute dachten, ihr Fernseher wäre kaputt gegangen oder irgendwie sowas, da hätten sie sich beschwert, weil man das nicht kennt aus irgendwelchen Serien oder Filmen, dass einfach gar nichts, die Tonschup einfach weg ist und es würde wirklich richtig auffallen, einfach plötzlich alles weg ist und es so wow. Wie bei meinem absoluten Lieblingsfilm, es gibt keinen mehreren Film als den, Star Wars The Last Jedi, wo ja auch dann diese Szene gibt, die Stärzestöhe war.
Echt, das ist Stille. Absoluten Lieblingsfilm, es gibt keinen besseren Film als den, Star Wars The Last Jedi, wo ja auch dann diese Szene gibt, die Sternzerstöre.
Echt, das ist Stille? Und da ist ja auch absolute Stille. Und deswegen haben ja alle Projectionists am Anfang die Blu-Ray bekommen und da halt den Film auf 70 mm. aber keiner weiß wasnung was das war. Und dann stand da drauf eine Note.
Achtung, bei Minute hm, ist komplette Stille, es ist nichts kaputt, es handelt sich um einen dramaturgischen Effekt. Ach cool. Was eigentlich cool ist. Sonst hätten die Lou Bega eingespielt aus Reflex. Ja, direkt oder Mao oder keine Ahnung, es gibt noch lange Lese, Altschreiben auch hier im Kino, irgendwas. Aber ich kann mir genau vorstellen, wie diese ganzen, die kennt man ja, diese umtriebigen Techniker im Kino dann sofort aber ich kann mir genau vorstellen, wie dann diese ganzen äh, die kennt man ja, diese
umtriebigen Techniker im Kino
dann sofort aufspringen und denken, was ist
jetzt hier los, was ist hier los, lieber erstmal abbrechen.
Ja, lieber erstmal abbrechen.
Ich glaube, das gab es beim New Magazin auch mal, dass es
irgendwie, ich glaube, Schwarzbild für eine längere Zeit
gab, wo auch irgendwie
bei der Einspielerschleife
da gab es doch diese Störung.
Mit der technischen Störung, das stimmt, das auch, aber ich glaube, es gab auch irgendwann mal Schwarzbild, wo es auch dann beim ZDF hieß, wo Leute, was ist da los, die ganz nervös geworden sind, wo man dann sagt, das ist der Gag. Ja, die Einspielerschleife hat auch die technische Abnahme beim ZDF nicht bestanden. Das sind einfach die Menschen, die sich ja gar nicht mit Inhalt auseinandersetzen und auch nicht wollen. Der einzige Job ist es, gibt's Bild, gibt's Ton, was ist mir egal, aber gibt's Bild und gibt's Ton.
Und wie laut ist das Bild und wie... auseinandersetzen und auch nicht wollen. Der einzige Job ist es, gibt's Bild, gibt's Ton.
Was ist mir egal, aber gibt's Bild und gibt's Ton.
Und wie laut ist das Bild und wie hell der Ton. Ja, genau. Das ist die beiden Aufgabe. Ist es zu hell, ist es zu laut, geht wieder zurück. Genau, dann haben die wirklich so Messpunkte und die jagen so eine Folge dann immer durch so ein Messgerät. Und dann spuckt er ihn dann aus, auf so Loch Papier, sagt er dann, diese Folge ist deutlich zu laut.
Und das Neomagazin war immer viel zu dunkel. Und dann spuckt er ihn dann noch aus, auf so Lochpapier, sagt er dann, diese Folge ist deutlich zu laut.
Und das Neomagazin war immer viel zu dunkel. Es gab jedes Mal die Anmerkung, es ist zu dunkel die Show.
Ja?
Ja. Weil die halt so ein bisschen diesen Cinescope-Look hat, hat so ein bisschen schön Tiefe, ist halt schön dunkel, nicht so gesättigt.
Und hat immer alle mal gesagt, na, ist dunkel, kann ich nicht machen. Und ist immer wieder durchgegangen. Wow, wow, sagten alle, ihre Fernseher sind kaputt. Vielen Dank an alle Hörer, die jetzt beim Dreh dabei waren. Stimmt, der Komparsendreh war. Es war fantastisch. Ihr wart fantastisch. Was sind das für Leute? Erzähl mal, was sind das so für Leute, die einerseits Podcast-Ufer haben, andererseits sagen, ich will Kompase sein? Also in einer Hinsicht sehr divers, weil es sind alle dabei. Gross, klein, dick, dünn, alt, jung, es waren viele Frauen dabei. Alt auch? Ja, nee, für den Dreh jetzt nicht, aber also. Ja, wenn du sagst, 18 bis 25, waren alle dabei. Es waren alle dabei, es waren 25 Jahre dabei, es war so ein, sechs, 20 Jahre dabei. Oh, oh, oh, oh. Und halt auch viele zwölf, also wirklich alles dabei und wirklich fantastische Leute, nur halt keine Diversität im Sinne der Hautfarbe, leider Gottes, wir sind einfach ein beisser Podcast. So, jetzt ist die Frage, ob wir da mal irgendwie uns anders aufstellen. Finde ich ja auch cool, wenn Thais vielleicht nochmal irgendwie eine Freundin von sich mitbringt oder sowas und wir uns halt in der Redaktion nochmal ein bisschen diverser aufstellen. Finde ich mal eine gute Task für 2020 nochmal. Aber ansonsten gute Leute? Voll gute Leute, super diszipliniert auch. Es war wirklich lustig, weil es war noch nie am Set so leise. Und es waren 80 Leute da im Set. Ja, die sind gewohnt zuzuhören, zum Podcast-Hörer. Ja, für eine wirklich anspruchsvolle Szene. Schlacht oder Kampf, Schiesserei? Genau, Kampfszene quasi. Also es driftet bis in Abendschaffel drei. Aber die Teutonen laufen in die ja rein okay und genau das war ein bisschen aufwendiger und ja tatsächlich war es noch nie so still und die waren unglaublich diszipliniert und dann war immer der take vorbei und es war war laut und wild und dann cut und alle waren ganz still haben mit grossen augen geguckt was ist passiert und jetzt passiert und ob die Kamera jetzt, was die Kamera jetzt macht und dann ob Anweisungen kommen und so. Und wahnsinnig gut auch die Abläufe gemerkt und so, was ja mit Anschlüssen und vielen Komparsen immer so eine Sache ist. Da muss ja immer alles eigentlich die gleiche Ablaufform haben, damit man überhaupt irgendwie eine Chance hat zu schneiden. Also wirklich fantastisch. Profis. Sehr gut. Ich bin sehr stolz auf euch, gut gemacht. Ich wusste, wir haben kompetente Hörer.
Ich habe so viel Lob in eurem Namen für euch bekommen. Wow. Da haben so viele gesagt, das sind fantastische Leute gewesen, weil die so gut mitgemacht haben. Also ich war ja auch dabei und musste das Gleiche sagen die ganze Zeit. Es war wirklich fantastisch. Richtig cool, vielen Dank. Sehr gut, herzlichen Glückwunsch, tolle Komparsen. Vielleicht sehen wir der Podcast mit den besten Komparsen.
Ja, vielleicht könnte man da mal so eine Olympiade machen, dass so die zehn grössten Podcasts antreten. Komparsen. Das ist eigentlich keine schlechte Idee. So Takeshis Castle für Podcasts, jeder schickt zehn Hörer und dann müssen die irgendwie so durch so eine Ballongrube durch oder so und wer durchkommt, gewinnt. Nee, wir sind diejenigen, da gewinnen noch gemischtes Hackpumper, wir sollten so ein Quiz, also ich glaube, wir sind so, keine Ahnung, Hauptstädte von Afrika zum Beispiel. Sehr gut, genau, Länder in Afrika. Länder in Afrika, ich fände ja, also ich fände gut, wenn wir, das finde ich super, eine Podcast-Olympiade, wo wir die Hörer aber gegeneinander antreten lassen, verschiedene Podcasts. Und ich glaube, es überschlagt den Raab, es gibt, er gewinnt alle Sportkategorien und wir gewinnen alle Quizkategorien. Und das ist so Geistermann? Ja, die gewinnen so Geschicklichkeitsspiele. Geschicklichkeit, hohe Fingerfertigkeit tatsächlich, ganz merkwürdig. Also wirklich alle Knobel. Die können fantastisch singen. Ja, finde ich eigentlich eine ganz gute Idee. Generell andere Leute. Und wir sitzen auf der Couch einfach. Nee, wir haben damit nichts zu tun. Ach, wir sind gar nicht anwesend bei der Sendung. Wir haben es weder geplant, noch sind wir dabei. Wir nehmen beide andere Sachen. Ja, finde ich gut. Podcast zum Beispiel.
Ja, wir lieben das.
Ne, das finde ich wirklich toll, also vielen Dank an euch. Das ist vielleicht schon spannend, weil es ist ja eine sehr, klar, eine sehr diverse Gruppe, demografisch divers, aber vielleicht haben die so einen Skill, der die alle vereint, weil sie uns hören. Ja, es kann gut sein, dass wir gewisse Leute anziehen einfach und die alle so einfach extrem gute Komparsen sind. Ist ja auch nicht leicht, Komparsen zu sein. Nee. Nee, ist wirklich nicht leicht. Vor allem Komparsen müssen ja immer sehr natürlich sein und das ist manchmal das Schwierigste tatsächlich, dann einfach ganz natürlich irgendwie zu laufen. Komparsen sind nie natürlich, das war natürlich. Ja? Ja, was hast du für Schauspieler? Ich bin extrem stolz auf euch. Ja. Und was Podcast UFO Hörer, glaube ich, auch noch auszeichnet ist, sie haben anscheinend sehr viele Ohrwürmer. Oh Gott. Werbung. Seid ihr Studenten und sucht fürs kommende Semester einen super leichten, leistungsfähigen Laptop? Seid ihr schwache Studenten, die keinen schweren Laptop tragen können? Und wisst auch nicht, ob Tablet oder Laptop oder was auch immer. Na dann kombiniert das Ganze doch einfach zu einem 360-Grad-faltbaren Convertible-Laptop. Denn das ist das Livebook U9310X. Das könnt ihr bei Alternate oder Cyberport mit dem Rabattcode. Und jetzt kommt's's, nur durch uns kriegt ihr das sogar günstiger. Mit vielleicht dem coolsten Rabattcode, den wir jemals hatten hier im Podcast. Und zwar, Achtung, der Rabattcode lautet Samurai 100. Samurai, nicht einfach nur Samurai. Der Rabattcode ist Samurai 100. Und damit bekommt ihr das gleicheste Tablet der Welt. Nicht umsonst, aber ihr kriegt darauf Rabatt. Das ist als Notebook und als Tablet nutzbar, hat eine hohe Sicherheit, Palm Security, Amp, ganztägige Akkulaufzeit, damit könnt ihr den ganzen Tag machen, was ihr wollt. Natürlich, ihr könnt Netflix-Serien anschauen, ihr könnt euch um eure Semesterarbeit kümmern oder einfach nur auf Instagram rumhängen, wie ihr es doch eh den ganzen Tag macht, sind wir ehrlich. Also viel Spaß mit deinem neuen Lieblingsgerät. Viel Spaß mit dem Fujitsu Convertible 360-Kart-Faltbar-Notebook. Macht's gut. Bis dann. 9-3-1-0. Ihr könnt auch Podcasts hören darauf. Nur mal so gesagt. Wir hören uns, bis gleich. Viel Spaß! Werbung Ohrwurm erkennen. Ohrwürmer haben gegen mich keine Chance. Ja, ich kenne das Wort gar nicht. Ich kenne jeden Song, jeden Komponisten, ich kenne alles. Und Stefan Titzer hat die Emergency-Ohrwurm-Hotline aufgemacht und hat gesagt, falls ihr da draußen Ohrwürmer habt, schickt sie einfach ein. Ich werde sie einfach entschlüsseln und werde euch aus eurer Misere holen, denn jeder weiß, wenn man einen Ohrwurm hat, muss man den Song mal anhören, um den Ohrwurm zu besiegen.
Aber wie soll man das machen, wenn man den Song nicht kennt?
Genau, ich habe einen bekommen, habe ich nicht erkannt, Ringer Boys. So, ich habe auch einige bekommen, weil wir haben gesagt, wir wollen live hier in der Sendung, wollen wir testen, ob Stefan Tietze seinem Versprechen tatsächlich standhalten kann. Stefan Tietze aus Carmen wettet, dass er Ohrwürmer erkennen kann, nur nach den Voice-Nachrichten, die Hörer uns eingesendet haben, in denen sie verzweifelt, jämmerlich in Not versuchen, ihren Ohrwurm mit schlechten Mikros darzustellen. Tom Hanks, glauben Sie, dass Stefan Tietze aus Carmen 26, that he can do it. Ich glaube, der kann's tun. Das ist immer wieder gut. Achtung, hier ist der erste Ohrwurm aus der Podcast UFO Community von Johannes. Moin Leute, hier mein Ohrwurm aus der Podcast-Ufo-Community von Johannes.
Moin Leute, hier mein Ohrwurm.
Leichter zum Reinkommen?
Das ist nicht Popcorn. Nein, das ist anderes.
Oh, Stefan, aber extrem viel Energie von Johannes. Genau, Herr Tietze, wir haben gesagt, die Idee war, Sie sagen den Titel und den Komponisten. Habt ihr auch so eine Brille auf? Aus ewigem Gründen darf ich auch nicht sehen. Mit so einem Wurm und einem Ohr drauf. Damit man da nochmal versteht, warum es in der Welt der Welt und dann schlägt ihr Thomas Gottschalk ins Gesicht aber ich glaube diese Folge wird richtig viele Ohrwürmer auslösen ganz die Bundesrepublik Deutschland alle U-Bahnen werden voll sein von von 18 bis 24 Weissen. Nein Popcorn ist da da da da da da da da da da da da genau das ging jetzt um den Song hier nicht ich prinzipiell Songs kenne, wollte ich sagen. Okay, okay, gut. Also, Stefan Tienzeit gewertet von zehn, er rät er zehn. Keine Ahnung? Keine Ahnung. Doch, ich kenne den Song, aber ich glaube, ich komme gar nicht drauf. Okay, gut, dann gehen wir weiter. Du musst sagen, wie es ist. Dann gehen wir weiter. Ich weiss es auch nicht. Was soll ich das denn wissen? Oh mein wissen? Du bist der Experte. Das ist die unbefriedigendste Show der ganzen Welt. Du kannst es doch nicht unaufgelöst lassen. Kommen wir zu Ohrwurm Nummer zwei. Hier ist Mark. Ey, wie heisst nochmal dieses ... Wie heisst das nochmal? Kind. Ja. Guter Song. Kein Name, wie der heißt. Das ist nicht dein fucking Ernst. Tom Hanks den Tränen nahe, Kopf in den Händen, Kopfschütteln! Und weil er gesagt hat, er kann, ich schaff's, muss er nicht so eine peinliche Wette erleden. Muss er in einen großen Senftopf steigen. Ja, auch ein guter Song. Vielen Dank für die ganzen Zollentipps, keine Ahnung, komme ich nie in den Raum. Ich kenne ihn auch, ich glaube, der heisst irgendwas mit Coffee, Coffee in the Morning.
Coffee in the Morning.
Naja, ich glaube nicht so direkt, aber irgendwas mit, es ist nicht Black Coffee, es gibt auch einen Song, der heisst Black Coffee, aber was wir auf jeden Fall machen werden, ist, wir veröffentlichen, weil das glaube ich ist auch eine ganz gute Idee, wir machen eine Spotify-Playlist, die Ohrwurm-Playlist, in der wir alle die Songs reinnehmen, weil wahrscheinlich sind ja bestimmte Songs prädestinierte Ohrwürmer. Das heißt, wenn man einen Ohrwurm hat, kann man einfach die Ohrwurm-Playlist anhören und alle Songs durchgehen und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sein Ohrwurm dabei ist, wird relativ hoch sein. Wir werden alle Songs, die eingeschickt wurden, reinpacken in die Ohrwurm-Playlist, damit ihr da
durchkommt. Boah, ich schwitze.
Ich wusste, dass ich das nicht gut kann,
weil mir oft keine Dinge einfallen.
Aber, oh fuck.
Okay, also, 0 von 2.
Wir gehen mal weiter
zum Ohrwurm von Sophie.
Ich hatte erst neulich einen Ohrwurm von
folgendem Lied.
Das ist von Sacha. Ja, ja.
Oder nicht?
Nee, das ist von Robert Williams.
Ja.
Ich war welches immer Sascha von Robert Williams.
Das ist diese Road to, Road to, oder Street Road to Mandalay?
Ich glaube auch, ehrlich gesagt, das ist einer seiner früheren Alben. So viel großer Roy Williams-Fan. Ich habe leider kein Internet hier, aber ich glaube, es ist Roy Williams. Ja, Leute, das ist nicht so einfach. Stefan! Ja, okay, alles klar. Ich weiß weiß nicht ob wir das einfach so in
die schnitzel können wir machen es ist es ist ein roger mendeley von
williams herzlichen glückwunsch wunderbar der regieassistent hat auch
mal einbekommen tom hengst steht auf tippt nervös herum. Okay, Tim sendet folgenden Ohrwurm. Dim, dim, dim, dididididididim, dim, dim, dim, dim, dim, dim, dim. Ja, wie gut ist das denn? Ich war noch nie so nervös in meinem ganzen Leben.
Ja, was ein guter Song.
Also, guter Musikgeschmack auf jeden Fall bei den Podcast-Uferhörern.
Im Studio eher angespannte Stimmung, peinliche Blicke im Publikum.
Tom Hanks versteckt sich hinterm Sofa.
Tom Cruise sucht ihn, verzweifelt, schaut wild umher. Oh Gott, ich weiß es nicht, ich komme nicht drauf. Könne ich jemanden anrufen? Nein. Keine Ahnung, komme ich nicht drauf. Wie soll man darauf kommen? Wie soll man darauf kommen? Ich habe das nicht im Kopf. Ich weiß auch nie, wie Songs heißen. Ja, aber das war dein Versprechen, Stefan. Ja, ich laber halt viel. Wir müssen die immer eine Stunde füllen, da muss man nochmal ab und zu behaupten, weil das gilt, die man nicht hat. Vielleicht mal was leichteres, wir haben nämlich noch einen von Simon und dem sind zumindest Textfragmente noch eingefallen. Also da ist es vielleicht leichter. Wir hören mal rein. Schifferhoi, Schifferhoi. Das habe ich mir im Leben noch nicht gehört. Aber ich glaube, der Song heißt Schifferhoi. Ich bin mir noch nicht sicher. Ja? Ja, bestimmt. Glaubst du, du kannst da helfen? Ja, Schifferhoi. Aber das hilft nicht so viel, ist ehrlich gesagt. Aber kein Seemannsgarn bei dir? Ich erinnere mich an Popcorn. Du hast jetzt eine Playlist gemacht, welche Songs das alles sein können. Songs like Popcorn von Hot Butter. Vielleicht dieses Seasons in the Sun. Es gibt einen Song von Hot Butter, der heißt Popcorn. Aber haben die alle Songs, die irgendwas mit Hot Butter zu tun haben? Ist das ein Zufall, dass die Band Hot Butter einen Song Pop kann?
Ja, ich, ohne Scheiss, wie kommen wir denn da jetzt drauf?
Okay, wir haben noch einen allerletzten von Jan.
Okay, okay, okay.
Nochmal wieder? Nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, nene, Wieder Road to Mandalay von Robbie Williams. Oh, that's okay. I think he did great. I think zero of ten is a great result. Yeah, good luck to him, but now I have to face my punishment. Is there a punishment in the show?
I don't really get the show. Nobody explained the show to me.
So, what's this giant bowl of mustard?
Is this the punishment?
Okay, well, okay, watch my movie, please. Was ist das für ein riesen Senfglas? Ist das eine Strafe?
Oh, die müssen wir wohl verraten. Ich glaube, gut, alles klar.
Watch my movie, please.
Guckt meinen Film.
Das war's von Wetten, das und von Stefan Tietzes Wette.
Ja, ich sage, wir haben eines gelernt.
Nehmt den Mund nicht zu voll.
Ja.
Don't overestimate yourself.
Ihr seid nichts wert. Ihr könnt nichts. Die Dinge, die ihr denkt, dass ihr gut könnt, könnt ihr vielleicht sogar besonders schlecht. Ja, schlechter als andere, sogar du unrepäsentiv neben mir gegenüber sitzend, kannst es besser als ich, der überhaupt dort erkennt es. Ja, mir war schon ehrlich gesagt, klar ist ja auch alles lustig und scherzhaft gemeint, natürlich kann ich das nicht, also war mir auch vorher klar. Aber ich hoffe, ihr konntet selber ein bisschen miträtseln und habt vielleicht ein paar...
Mir geht es so schlecht jetzt.
Wir werden natürlich alle versuchen, alle eure mal aufzuklären und machen eine Playlist, damit ihr euch das anhören könnt, damit ihr jetzt nicht den Rest der Zeit geplagt.
Steffa, du hast es völlig außer sich, völlig neben der Spur, denkt nach.
Ja, wegen der Melodie, wegen der lächerlichen Melodie.
Nein, das ist der Wenger-Bass, den hatten wir doch schon. D-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d- haben. Für den Rest der Zeit, aber ihr habt den Vorteil, ihr könnt jetzt, weil ihr Zeitreisende seid und in der Zukunft lebt, könnt ihr jetzt die Playlist euch angucken, die wir posten. Wie wollen wir das hinbekommen? Wir haben so viele Musiker, als hast du unsere Intros mal gehört. Wir haben richtig viele Musiker, die kennen sich aus mit Musik. Ich will auch Musik. Ich stehe jetzt bei Wikipedia, weil ich es sehr lustig finde. Aber wenn es mir nicht jetzt gelöscht wird, dann weiß ich auch nicht. Genau, so mit ihm Ex-Musiker steht dann da, Musiker bis 2020 hat er seine Musikkarriere öffentlich beerdigt. Jetzt habe ich so Playlist schon auf, die heißen Songs Everybody Knows. Ja, except you, except Stefan. Die ist schon mal sechs Stunden lang. Die kann sich einfach komplett hören. Und die beginnt mit Telefon von Lady Gaga. Ich glaube, es ist aber eine gute Idee, eine Ohrwurm-Playlist zu haben, die man im Notfall als Not-Hotline dann sozusagen, vielleicht müssen wir auch eine Notfall-Hotline einrichten, 117117, falls man einen Ohrwurm hat. Und dann hat man so auf der anderen Seite so sämtliche Ohrwurmsongs, die so zehn Sekunden lang angespielt werden, danach wird der Titel genannt und dann durch. Ich glaube, das ist eine gute Idee. Ich glaube, Hotlines, damit kann man richtig viel Geld verdienen. Stefan, ich merke, du bist nicht bei mir, du bist wo ganz anders. Nein, nein, stop the beat, glaube ich. Stop the beat? So was. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, den, den. Der Rest der Folge besteht nur darauf, dass wir Gedanken verloren, irgendwelche extrem catchy Melodien brummeln. Genau, aber das finden wir auf jeden Fall noch raus. Ich möchte nämlich noch ein paar in der laufenden Folge noch lösen. Aber ich kann es jetzt ein bisschen vergessen, ehrlich gesagt, für den Rest. Was bist du denn? Ich finde auch ganz toll, jetzt ein kleiner Einblick, sehr privat, erstmal ganz, ganz vielen Dank an alle, die ihre Ohrwürmer eingesendet haben. Vielen Dank, voll cool. Und es ist ja auch ein sehr intimer Einblick, weil das sind ja keine Sänger, die das dann irgendwie singen, sondern so vor sich hin brummeln. Was ist denn deine Technik, wenn du eine Melodie, also machst du den oder machst du was ist deine Vokabel, also was ist deine Silbe? Aber ist es bei jedem Song anders. Ja, ich mache die Töne schon lautmalerisch nach.
Es ist dort, ne, es ist dort.
I was walking down the window.
Down the window.
I was walking in.
Ich glaube, es ist irgendwas mit Kaffee oder Coffee oder irgendwie sowas.
Podcasts sind eh schon nervig, wenn Leute nicht auf Namen kommen oder sowas.
Wir machen eine ganze fuckingangenrubrik da drauf. Podcast UFO in Chill, irgendwelche Leute haben gerade Sex, werden nebenbei, ne ne ne, ne, was ist das nochmal, ne ne, völlig wahnsinnig. Ich glaube, diese Folge wird unsere Hörerzahl halbieren, weil die Leute einfach sagen, ich komme nicht mehr drüber weg. So, ich gebe jetzt ein Plagiat voneinander, weil es The Dust. Nein, das funktioniert doch nicht. Doch, so was funktioniert. Mich ärgert es, ich habe keine Ahnung. Aber mach mal, aber hast du das Hast du das noch? Irgendwie das ist so I was walking down the I was walking down the window when I walked into the window, then I looked through the window. Soll ich jetzt Wenn I was walking down the window when I walked into the window, then I looked through the window, when I saw you in the window, then I opened up the window and asked you to get out of the window. So geht das doch. Stop fish down the window. Down in Memphis. Ja gut, da ist es sehr riskant.
And he's just, I was walking down Main Street, Chicago Main Street, Postal Code 56718.
Wow, so geheimt aber.
Aber es ist einfach. I was walking down the street window, saw a donkey.
I was walking down the street.
And I saw a donkey through the window, then I closed up the window.
I have to clean my window.
The most annoying song in history.
Walking past the window.
Was, woher suchst du denn?
I was walking window song.
Mach doch Lyrics. I was walking window song. Mach doch Lyrics.
I was walking window lyrics.
Lyrics.
I was
through a brick through a window.
Vergiss es.
Wir werden das wirklich alles nachreichen.
Das ist das Letzte, ich hasse es.
Wir werden am Ende der Folge, ich werde sämtliche
Orbe recherchieren und Leute
damit, weil ich weiss, wie manche Menschen jetzt leiden gerade, habt noch Geduld, ich werde am Ende der Folge sämtliche Orbe recherchieren und Leute damit, weil ich weiß, wie manche Menschen jetzt leiden gerade,
habt noch Geduld, ich werde am Ende der
Folge sämtliche Titel nennen.
Ja. Ich werde das reinschneiden,
weil ich will euch echt erlösen, ich will nicht,
dass ihr jetzt hier im Limbo hängenbleibt.
Ja.
Der genervteste DJ
der Welt auch. Ja, komm, keine Ahnung.
Nee, wer weiß. Keine Ahnung, scheiße. Ich we es nicht. Ist es der Song, ist nicht meine Playlist. Habe ich auch mal tatsächlich einen DJ sagen hören, das ist nicht meine Playlist. Das ist nicht meine Playlist. Also ein DJ, der sich für die Musik entschuldigt, ist immer ein Zeichen für eine richtig geile Stimmung. Da weiss er einfach, dass er eine gute Stimmung macht. Wahnsinn. Wirst du jemals wieder glücklich werden? Ich war noch nie so gestresst von einer Folge Podcast-Sofo. Ich bin so, mir geht es so schlecht. Du, da hast du dir selber den Kaffee eingeschüttet. Coffee? I always have having. Du hast das Fenster aufgemacht, jetzt musst du auch durchsteigen. Ich hoffe, du hast was gelernt. Ich hoffe, du hast gelernt, dass du schäbig bist, dass du nichts kannst. Ich will den Mut nicht mehr so vollnehmen, werde ich jetzt. Ich werde jetzt ein bisschen dämlicher sein wieder. Ja, du hast deine Musiker-Credibility auch komplett beerdigt. Das stimmt nicht. Ich halte das ja, ich halte Gedächtnis und Actual Music geht es ja für was anderes, aber gut. Beerdige ruhig mal. Aber bab auch, bab geht auch. Ja, mit M, ne? Kommen wir so auf die Kadenz an am Ende. Ich müsste jetzt ganz viele Fremdwörter, damit man mir irgendwas noch glaubt in der Hinsicht, aber Gott im Himmel, ey. Es ist vor allem, unabhängig von der Demütigung, ist es aber auch gerade einfach scheiße, diese ganzen Orbe zu haben. Führst du es nicht? Tut mir leid.
Also bei mir ist es so,
ich weiß, dass ich zwei rausfinden kann.
Dieses I walked in the window und
bin ich mir hundertprozentig sicher,
dass wenn ich eine Stunde und das Internet
habe, findet man das raus. Easy, easy.
Die anderen sind schwieriger.
Also
da müsste man vielleicht dann irgendwie in die Charts gucken oder so, aber da habe ich weniger. Ich glaube, das ist relativ aktuell. Also aktuell ist für mich alles nach 2001. Das ist so Bruno Mars irgendwas vielleicht, keine Ahnung. So was in der Eckung, es hat so ein bisschen Bruno Mars. Stop the Beat. Ja, 40.000 Songs auf You Can Stop the Beat. Ja, You Can't Stop The Beat. Maybe we can't. We just can't stop the beat. Warum versuchen Leute immer noch den Beat zu stoppen? Ja, genau. It cannot be stopped. It just cannot. Wer versucht den Beat zu stoppen? Glaubst du, alle Songtitel wurden schon verwendet? Weil es gibt ja wahnsinnig viele Songs auf Spotify. Ich habe zum Beispiel mal das Spiel gemacht, überleg dir einen besonders bescheuerten Songtitel und tipp ihn mal bei Spotify ein, gibts den Song. Also irgendwie dann so, keine Ahnung, Blind Because of Your Love oder irgendwie sowas. Your Love makes me wanna dance on the roof. Irgend so ein Nonsense einfach. Gibt's, gibt's einfach. Your love makes me sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze's einfach. Your love makes me sneeze, sneeze, sneeze, sneeze.
Sneeze love.
Sneeze, sneeze love. Ja, band.
I sneeze when I love you.
Erfolgreichste Band der Achtziger.
Gibt's einfach. Gibt's einfach.
Und wo ich mir auch denke, eigentlich muss jeder Songtitel doch schon irgendwo besetzt sein.
Klar, dafür ist natürlich auch, ich verstehe deinen Blick, Names, Names, Names, Names da,
um da einfach so ein bisschen das Pad zu brechen, um da rauszukommen. Aber sowas ist schon, es gibt glaube ich einfach da schon alles. Crazy in Love zum Beispiel ist ja ein Song, der rauskam in erst letzter Zeit. Ich glaube, es gab schon vorher ein Crazy in Love. Genau, es muss doch davor schon jemand, also ich meine, die Idee, dass Liebe einen verrückt macht, ist jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig originell. Deswegen lobe ich mir jemanden wie The Weeknd, der I can feel my face jetzt zumindest sagt. Also er ist schon so weit ... Man muss ja übertreiben. Also was macht Liebe noch? Das ist ja die Frage, die Popmusik sich ja da anstellt. Was macht Liebe noch? Wird es immer schwerer, Musik zu schreiben oder Liebe zu beschreiben? Ich meine, du kannst nicht mehr ... Vor allem, ich glaube, der Bauch ist völlig raus. I can't feel my face. Ich glaube, genau, jetzt geht es ins Gesicht, weil der Bauch ist raus. Wir hatten Flugzeuge im Bauch, wir hatten Schmetterlinge im Bauch, wir hatten Ohrnessen im Bauch, wir hatten Bäuche im Bauch, wir hatten alles im Bauch. Ich glaube, der Bauch ist einfach, wie heißt der Song? Yummy, yummy, yummy, I got love bugs. Ja, aber so heißt der Song nicht. Du hast nichts gelernt! Na, aber wie ist... Du hast nichts gelernt, Schiff und Tietze! Ich stelle mich immer noch hin und behaupte, wenn ich... Natürlich, locker. Tom Hanks stocksauer, nichts gelernt, aber... Dafür kann ich super gut, wenn ihr mir Zitate schickt, kann ich super gut euch sagen, von welchem Autoren die kommen.
Aber ich glaube, Bauch ist durch, was Liebe angeht. Jetzt geht es vielleicht eher so in die Gesichtsgegend so.
My ears are itching because I love you so much oder sowas in der Richtung.
My nose is red, my nose is bleeding.
My eyebrows twitch uncontrollably.
I can't stop thinking about you. Meine Eibroweys twitch. Meine Eibroweys twitch. Meine Eibroweys dance für dich. Ich weiß nicht, ob das dich anzutragen würde, aber ich habe dieses kleine Ding mit meinem Einen in Klammern. Doch, disappointment. Ich liebe Songs mit Klammern. Aber es ist schon so, dass eigentlich Songs mit Klammern sagen immer, finde ich, weil oft ist das dahinter der Pina Colada-Song. Ah, das ist nett, aber das ist nett, das ist eine Hilfe. Das ist Hilfe für uns, genau in der Situation, in der wir gerade sind. Ja genau, The Coffee Song bräuchten wir. The Coffee Song. Sowas in der Richtung. The Window Coffee Song.
Coffee kann nicht vorkommen.
Ich glaube schon.
Vielleicht verwechsel ich es auch mit Black Coffee.
Weil es gibt einen Song, der heißt Black Coffee.
Der einzige Song, bei dem ich jemals
bei SingStar 10.000 Punkte die volle
Punktzahl geschafft habe, ist Black Coffee.
Aber auch ein bisschen mit Schummeln.
Aber ich bin immer noch sehr stolz darauf. Werden wir kurz rein? Ja, wie? Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, aber es geht eigentlich nur um den Refrain. Was für ein Singster war das? Ich weiss nicht, irgendein Singster 90s oder sowas. Stefan, ich glaube, wir können nicht einfach so Songs spielen. Anspielen, doch. Nein, das ist die älteste Urheberrecht-Lüge aller Zeiten. Unter drei Sekunden darf man. Es ist falsch, schlicht falsch. Aber ich meine, es gab tatsächlich noch nie ein Problem bei Podcasts. Bei YouTube wirst du ja komplett weggestrikt, wenn du Songs drin hast. Bei Podcasts noch nie. Ich glaube, es kümmert sich einfach, wir sind gerade in der goldenen Ära der Podcast. Aber Spotify hat zum Beispiel auch die Rechte an dem Song. Das denke ich mir. Allerdings bei Spotify, ihr könnt ja auch nebenan klicken, kurz dreimal nach rechts und dann bist du doch bei Black Coffee von All Saints und Mark Stand. Mark Stand war dabei? Mark Stand. Mark Stand. Weiß ich aus dem Kopf. Glaubst du, irgendwann gehen Popsongs nicht mehr über Liebe? Glaubst du, wir emanzipieren uns irgendwann gesellschaftlich von dem Konzept Liebe, dass man irgendwie Popsongs dann eher über politische Themen macht oder über Bienen oder sowas? Ja. Ich finde es generell cool, mal andere Themen anzusprechen, wie zum Beispiel das Bienensterben und generell, wie man mit Wespen umgehen sollte.
Flight of the Bumblebee? Wespen tun ja auch was. Ja, der Hummelflug.
Aber ist Bumblebee Hummel? Nicht Biene? A Bee ist Biene, ne? Ja.
Übrigens, ich muss nochmal die Serie Barry empfehlen, ganz fantastisch, mit Bill Hader. Da gibt es nämlich auch eine Szene, wo die Polizisten dann irgendwann sagen, jetzt verhaften wir ihn, und dann meinte einer, I've prepared a playlist for this, wenn sie da hinfahren, um jemanden zu verhaften, und dann macht er die Playlist an, und es ist Flight of the Bumblebees, und dann meinte seine Kollegin, maybe you thought of Ride of the Valkyries?
Ah, fuck.
Also der Valkyrenritt von Wagner, kennt man vielleicht aus Apocalypse Now und er hat Flight of the Bumblebees gemacht.
Grandiöse Szene, toll.
Und er so macht ganz saurig die Playlist wieder aus.
Und extra in den Playlist gemacht für den Moment, wenn sie fahren, um ihn zu verhaften. Ich sag nicht wen. Aber Ride of the Valkyries war ja damals schon, weil dieses Jahr ist ja der... Also nur ganz kurz für all die, nicht Wagner-Valkyrie. Da ist immer gespielt, wenn irgendwas Episches passiert und jetzt gleich los. Ist ja eigentlich die Overtüreüre zum dritten Akt der Walküre, die zweite Oper aus dem Ring.
Und die ganze Oper wurde halt gespielt und es war danach wohl so, dass man zu Wagner gegangen ist und gesagt hat, kannst du mal einen Walkhörnerin spielen? Es war damals schon so ein Ohrwurm, dass Leute aus der Oper gegangen sind und diesen Ohrwurm hatten. Du hast in der Zeit von klassischer Musik einen Ohrwurm.
Du hast einmal in deinem Leben eine Sinfonie und hast einen Ohrwurm und den Rest deines Lebens Lebenslebens, nefragmenten hat oder sowas, finde ich auch total spannend. Und ich habe, glaube ich, einen Wortohrwurm schon seit ich 15 bin oder so. Immer wieder, ich will nicht sagen, was es ist, weil es ist ja privat. Es ist meine Adresse. Aber auch ganz merkwürdiges Phänomen. Habe ich schon von ein paar Leuten gehört. Das ist, glaube ich, eines dieser Phänomene, die noch nicht ausführlich benannt wurden, aber die trotzdem alle haben. Weil das Phänomen Ohrwurm hat ja jeder. Und es gibt ein Wort dafür, aber es gibt bestimmt noch andere Dinge, die hat auch jeder. Aber jeder denkt, das habe nur ich, weil es dafür keinen Begriff gibt und man nicht darüber redet. Satztrauma. Oder Satzwurm oder Wortwurm. Wortwurm. Wortwurm ist bestimmt irgendwie so eine Webseite, wo man so für Kinder so eine Nübe nach... Oh, ich sehe die Sache vor mir. Ja. Mit so einem kleinen Bauarbeiter, der sagt, Under Construction. Wortwurm ist bald wieder zurück für euch. Und alle so gute Facts. Nachricht wurde geschrieben 2006. Ja. Ist bald wieder da. Wortwurm enttäuscht mich seit 2006. It's a Wordworm-Production. Es wäre sehr häufig, aber so ... Fastworm. Ohrwürmer. Ich bin immer noch von ... Ja, ist ein bisschen monothematisch, aber aus dem Schnitt. Dann schneidet man so eine Szene ewig. Und dann habe ich auch aus der Serie ganz viele Ohr viele Orbe immer. Und aus Staffel zwei habe ich immer noch Dan, wie er Hanzu, Hanzu sagt. Weil Lisa überrascht die Jungs in Moritz Zimmer. Und Moritz hat noch seine Handschuhe an, mit denen er die Drogen verpackt. Und Dan ruft ganz laut Hanzu, Hanzu. Und das habe ich im Kopf, weil es war sich befriedigend zu sagen. Es klingt wie eine japanische Übereidigung, Hanzu. Vielleicht heißt das auf Japanisch noch Hanzu. Hanzu. Hanzu! Die haben ja auch so manche Begriffe, die so aus anderen Sprachen kommen, die dann einfach so ein bisschen japanisch klingen. Irgendwie so Ice Cream wird dann einfach japanisch ausgesprochen und dann heißt Ice Cream oder sowas. Ja, das stimmt. Ja. Das freue ich mich immer, wenn man was wiedererkennt. Wenn da so ein ganz langer japanischer Satz kommt und dann erkennt man zwischendurch Kevin Spacey. Und dann denkt man, oh, okay, jetzt weiß ich, worum es geht. Ich spreche japanisch. Stocksauer, er ist sehr wütend und er redet von Ice Cream. Was ist da geschehen? Was ist passiert? What has happened? Gibt es für dich dieses Jahr Urlaub eigentlich noch? Nö, schön zu Weihnachten erst wieder. Schön Weihnachten, Silvester, noch mal schön die Jungs, die Truppe. Weil wegfahren, ich wollte dieses Jahr eigentlich noch mal schön irgendwo wegfahren, aber jetzt weiß ich nicht wie und ob und warum. Schön nach Jordanien oder sowas. Ja, genau, schön, wo man sonst nicht hinwollen würde. Ja, irgendwo, schön nach Senegal oder einfach mal hin. Oder sollte man jetzt irgendwo hin, wo es nie wieder so leer wird. Ich habe ein bisschen Corona-Fear of Missing Out, Corona-Fomo. Okay, dass du jetzt die Situation nicht ausnutzt, oder wie? Genau, ein Kumpel von mir hat mir das auch geschrieben. Und der hat das Gegenteil. Wow, das ist wirklich schon die zweite Phase der Pandemie. Phase eins, Panik, Phase zwei, verpasse ich nicht irgendwas. Ja, das habe ich. Aber mein Kumpel hat das quasi, Dinge zu machen, obwohl man sie nicht machen sollte. Und ich habe das in eine andere Richtung. Ich habe totale Angst, Dinge nicht zu machen, die jetzt so geil sind wie noch nie. Und wie sie auch nie wieder sein. Freizeitparks, glaube ich, sind richtig geil. Ich glaube auch, ich glaube auch so was wie Venedig, eine unglaublich Touristen überlaufende volle Kackstadt, glaube ich, jetzt gerade, ich finde wahrscheinlich fantastisch, ganz leer. Nie wieder werden wir das so sehen. Waren da nicht Delfine unterwegs irgendwie? Delfine waren in der Stadt unterwegs. Am Anfang der Pandemie, wo sich so die Nachrichten überschlagen haben, und dann ist es plötzlich wieder Delfine in Venedig. Aber das war auch dann schnell vergessen, wenn andere Sachen bekamen, wo die ganze Welt bricht zusammen. Und jetzt sind wir an dem Punkt, wo wir sagen, ganz kurz nochmal zurück zu den Delfinen. Genau, soll ich nochmal ganz kurz, warum darf man die nicht füttern? Warum darf man die nicht so auf den Arm nehmen, dass man dann so Futter auf den Arm legt und dann kommen die Delfine auf den Arm und dann warum darf man das nicht machen, ja weil die platzen dann, die quälen auf, das darf man nicht machen. Gerade neulich war ich an einem Tag irgendwo kurz in der Wildnis und hatte dann kein, weil wir da gedreht haben, kein Internet. Man wusste so angsteinflössend auf dem Bildschirm. Wir laufen noch.
Ja, ja.
Da habe ich, einen Tag lang hatte ich kein Internet und ich war so gestresst, davon kein Internet zu haben. Da habe ich mein iPad gehabt und dann bin ich auf Facebook gegangen und habe dann noch gesehen die Nachrichten vor Corona. Weil das letzte Mal, als ich das iPad benutzt habe, war tatsächlich noch vor Corona im Januar. Da gab es das schon, aber es war kein Thema. Und es war so interessant, diesen Feed durchzugehen und haben gesagt, was machst du da, kannst du so schlecht ohne Internet leben? Ich habe gesagt, ja, ich gucke mir Facebook-Feeds an, die noch geladen haben von dem nächsten 20. Januar, das war es 20. Und es war ganz spannend, was für Belanglosigkeiten es da ging. Völlig egale News waren riesig. Und danach plötzlich halt weltverändernde News. Ich glaube, in der Zeit hätte auch jetzt irgendwie so, ja, Aliens sind in Peru gelandet. Wäre so untergegangen so ein bisschen. Ja, total. So eins nach dem anderen. Save it. Aliens sind in Peru gelandet, aber auch, genau, aber in Italien gibt es neue Tote. Ja, und sie sind gelb. Okay, alles klar, Hammer, weiter. So, wie können wir jetzt die pandemie in griffen bekommen aber eigentlich cool mal so das internet von einer anderen zeit zu scrollen eigentlich auch nicht mal so projekte von zum beispiel keine ahnung 1989 mal wie würde facebook aussehen das wäre meine gute kunstinstallation also ich meine ist ja eigentlich also irgendwo wird Internet ja gespeichert. Und jetzt sagen wir mal so 2100, wo ja wirklich unsere Zeit... Wie sagt man das dann so, 2100? Nee, das ist doch nicht 2100. Dann sagt man 2100 oder 2100. 2100. Ich glaube, es sind 2110, wie man jetzt auch sagt, 2020. Ach so. Aber 2100 liegt nach Ausdruck der Zahl.
Ich glaube, das würde ein Alien sagen. Wann bist du geboren? Ja, 1989.
2100. Verhaftet ihn. Aber dann ist ja unsere Zeit wirklich antik. Aber man könnte sagen, hey, Geschichtsklasse, wir nehmen gerade irgendwie Anfang des 21. Jahrhunderts durch, hier habe ich diesen winzigen Mini-USB-Stick, der so klein ist wie ein Sandkorn, da ist das gesamte Internet vom Jahr 2020 drauf, das tue ich jetzt in eure Gedankenkammer, in eure Gehirnchips, wird hochgeladen in eure Braincloud und dann könnt ihr mal surfen im Internet von 2020 und guckt euch mal um, wie es da war. Mega. Das ist ja eigentlich ganz geil, dass du heute eine Zeitung liest von 1909. Ja, da habe ich auch immer ein Ohr von, obwohl ich kein großer Fußballfan bin, im Jahre 1909 da war ein Stern geboren.
Das war auf der Musik von Amazing Grace die Hymne von Borussia Dortmund. Im Jahre 1909 da war ein Stern geboren und der Stern der heißt Borussia. Siehe.
Vor allem Fans.
Aber man hat das immer.
Man hat immer eine komische... Ich glaube, du hast gerade noch mal alle wütend gemacht. Alle wütend. Weil nicht Fussballfans nervt, weil es Fussball ist. Fussballfans nervt, weil es nicht ihre Mannschaft ist. Und zwei Leute grönen vielleicht mit ihrem Toaster, mit ihrem Borussia Dortmund-Toaster, den sie feierlich noch mal draufdrücken. Der singt ja her. Feiern jetzt gerade. Man kann das manchmal nicht beschwören. Es kommen nicht die Gedanken in den Kopf, die man braucht. Es kommen häufig, vergisst man Dinge, die wichtig sind. Stefan, ich hoffe, dein Selbstbewusstsein ist nicht allzu sehr geknickt nach dieser enttäuschenden Wette. Ich hasse diese Folge. Die Folge heißt Enttäuschung. Nee, ja, oder an den Pranger stellen oder sowas. Können wir mal eine andere Perspektive. Gut, gerne. Ich werde sämtliche Ohrwürmer recherchieren und jetzt gleich noch anhängen an die Folge, damit ihr entlassen seid, damit ihr nicht den Rest eures Lebens gefangen seid. Ansonsten machen wir auch eine Playlist und dann könnt ihr euch durchhören. Und eigentlich dürfte es jetzt nie wieder Ohrwürmer geben. Und falls ihr selber noch Go-To-Orwurm-Songs habt, schreibt mir die, dann füge ich die in die Playlist ein. Und dann können wir die Welt, vielleicht, ich meine, wir können nicht alles heilen, wir können nicht die Armut verändern, wir können nicht den Weltfrieden bringen, vielleicht können wir den Menschen ein bisschen Linderung zu Ohrwürmern. Ein kleiner lustiger Party-Tipp, spielt mal eure ersten Shazam-Songs vor. Also wenn man aber abends nicht weiß, was für eine Musik man anmachen soll oder so. Ich habe sehr gute Erfahrungen damit gemacht, es ist auch ein guter Icebreaker, neue Leute kennenzulernen. Einfach den allerersten Song, den man Shazamt hat, den man in seinem Shazam-Verlauf noch hat, abspielen, alle müssen nacheinander rum und dann geht es immer weiter, bis man beim heutigen letzten Shazam-Song angekommen ist. Mensch, aber du bist ja die richtige Party-Maus.
Das ist wirklich unglaublich Spaß.
Das macht wirklich Spaß.
Was für alberne Scheisse.
Weil es ist oft so Songs, die man kennt,
weil es ist ja entweder Songs, die man hört und man weiss, die würde ich jetzt nie wiederfinden,
deswegen schieselte ich die, damit ich den abgespeichert habe.
Oder es ist ein Song, auf den man partout nicht kommen will,
wie der heisst. Aber es sind so Songs
wie Faith von George Michael, die man ja kennt,
aber man kommt, auf den man partout nicht kommen will, wie der heißt.
Aber das sind so Songs wie Faith von George Michael, die man erkennt, aber man kommt nicht auf den Titel.
Wie jetzt bei allen Szenen-Songs.
Die würde ich gerne schasamen.
Genau, mach das mal, sehr lustig.
Gut, sehr gut.
Cooler Tipp, haut rein, macht's gut.
Wir wünschen euch eine schöne Woche.
Voll.
Bis dann sind wir wieder da.
Haut rein.
Haut rein, wir heben ab, macht's gut. Ciao.
Ciao, ciao. It dann sind wir wieder da. Haut rein. Haut rein. Wir heben ab, macht's gut. Ciao.
It's a voice-by-production. allzu lange auf heißen Kohlen sitzen müsst. Wir fangen auch direkt mit einer Entschuldigung an, denn der erste Urwurm von Johannes, der ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne ne
stellte sich tatsächlich als Popcorn von Hot Hot Butter raus. Also Stefan lag hier tatsächlich richtig.
Ob ihm das das Selbstbewusstsein gestärkt hätte für alle weiteren Urwimmer, weiß man nicht,
aber hier muss die Redaktion sich tatsächlich entschuldigen.
Da lag Stefan tatsächlich richtig. Machen wir weiter mit Marks Ohrwurm, dem Das ist Toms Diner von Suzanne Vega. Und um ganz kurz die Textstellen zu zitieren, an die wir uns nicht richtig erinnern konnten mit Window und Morning. Also es geht los mit I'm sitting in the window at the diner on the corner, I'm waiting at the counter for the man to pour the coffee. Und später heißt es nochmal He's looking out the window. Der Titel hat aber weder was mit Coffee noch mit Window zu tun. Also das hat eine Weile gedauert, das zu finden, das Lied. Von Sophie konnten wir schon auflösen, es ist Robert Williams wrote to Mandalay. Tim war etwas anspruchsvoller mit dem dem dem dddd dem und das ist Need You Tonight von Inks, I-N-X-S geschrieben.
Simon hatte seinen nautischen Schlager gesungen.
Und es gibt ein Lied, das heißt Schiff Ahoi von den Calimeros.
Das wird's wohl sein, Simon. Ganz viel Spaß damit.
Zum Abschluss Jan.
Keine Ahnung, den Ohrwurm von Jan konnten wir nicht rausfinden, wir haben nichts gefunden, Jan, es tut uns wirklich leid, du musst weiter in deinem Ohrwurm-Limbo weiterhängen, falls ihr da draußen den Ohrwurm von Jan erkannt habt, dann meldet euch doch bitte, dann können wir das nächste Woche auflösen. Ansonsten auch noch mal von meiner Seite eine kleine Entschuldigung für diese Folge, die wahrscheinlich sehr viele von euch in die absolute Ohrwurm-Hölle geworfen hat.
Es tut uns sehr, sehr leid, die Playlist ist ab jetzt online, das heisst, ihr könnt euch da vielleicht ein bisschen Erholung suchen und vielleicht den ein oder anderen Ohrwurm austreiben, ansonsten macht's gut.
So viel aus der Redaktion, bis nächste Woche, tschüss.